you  hey I'm Aaron taylor-johnson I'm in  downtown LA shooting DQ a huge comic  book reader at all so now it's so  dictated by who the actors are kind of  playing the superheroes nowadays right  so I know Downey jr. is Iron Man or you  know even Henry Cavill now Superman I  have a huge respect for all of them I  think they're all pretty impressive  PCAST was a lot of more fighting styles  and we did a lot of boxing and jiu-jitsu  and which is great because you end up  learning new techniques and skills in  something my martial arts and English is  great and just do night shoots and  things like that and you know constantly  be running with a whole load of gear on  I said would be physically demanding my  most kick-ass injury was when I was six  and I slid down a banister with a few  mates it had one of those impresses of  knobs at the end of the banister piece  so it because I was [ __ ] paying for  you